c'est beaucoup chez des doigts décrétant
on arrivait à paris mais finalement on
sait très peu de choses de ton enfance
au japon dione où elle tenait à côté
d'eux mais c'est ton petit dire à
trotter de kyoto
ouais ouais j'ai fait que je sois 10 et
un rabbin
à bas les cours d'eau
le monde à tokyo dix candidats n'y avait
que hakim ait dit un jour tu as pris
l'avion avec un peu d'argent et a
débarqué à paris
oui j'ai des yeux bruns séance où diaby
et j'habite qui habitait napalm moi et
mon neveu a pas comment vous pouvez télé
qui devait changer le construire mais
son appartement je devais c'est mal me
d'euros mais c'est donner de l'argent
pour leur bien ah ben voilà
avec ce lien j'ai décidé de ne pas
livrer les bleus moment pour commander
j'étais quoi ta première impression
quand est arrivée à paris qu'est ce que
tu faisais tu traîner dans les rues
oui une première impression était
dissimulée a avec bateau est ici à
libérer gars de llo ouais moi d'imaginer
beaucoup de lumière
couples ayant habillé tout ça d'ici à
libé le et j'aime bien ouais 65 65
un logiciel dégâts de lyon il y avait
pas donné on y avait des pertes pour des
cieux mais c'était quoi tes premiers du
premier boulot à paris c'était quoi
pendant six mois des pieds pas
travailler ici
avec le projet vous pouvez jamais pensé
qu'ils pouvaient pas les mets
et après six mois vraiment je dis plus
rien d'une nouvelle répartition des
forces et j'ai dit moi même avant avant
par des diaporamas me plaisait quelques
secondes ouais ils étaient tous des
simples sisal et les libéraux oui
riposter
teychenné dessin a récemment beaucoup
reviennent parce que c'est pas toi qui a
inventé un peu les les défilés à grand
spectacle
les shows parce que moi j'ai vu des
choses toit où il y avait des éléphants
il y avait des chevaux blancs c'est pas
toi qui a inventé tout ça c'est pas
inventé
c'est un duo bien comme ça oui et
beaucoup changent parce que
quand on a commencé le défilé est
d'abord je connaissais pas vraiment laid
des plastiques et du coup j'ai pas
tellement de mannequins et j'ai connu
une nuit qui occupent occupaient les
bookings 1
dans le top model c'est elle qui m'a
aidé à mener tous les modèles tous les
top models pour faire téléphoner
ouais c'était vraiment un après il ya eu
l'époque des grandes fêtes du palace
mais c'est comme tout comme ça que je
t'ai connu grande fête du palace au
début à l'epr il ya dans le fait que
seule salle du palace avant que ça
s'appelle de privilèges avec le
fabricant sort mois maintenant
ce soit pour moi j'y vais beaucoup n'ont
pas du tout dans cette agence revienne
pour le crois pas tu viens au badhus des
fois bien sûr il ya te plaît oui il ya
eu un parfum faut dire la vérité qui
s'est pas très bien passée c'était pas
ça pas marché parce que ce n'est pour
nous pour moi c'est une époque bbc et
puis on n'a pas vraiment de travailler
au fond
c'est un poète et un coup comme ça voilà
oui oui et celui là de parfois il va
s'appeler comment et qu'elles ont tout
simplement oui inquiète la police
un cas choisi le jute à tous choisis
la danse c'est joli respect et bae mais
tient bon
j'aime quand ça sort quand c'est un
mauvais
elles sont très bons ouais ça va marcher
tu penses que tu as apporté quoi à la
mode un jour dans les bourgs histoire
quand on regardera de toi dans les
livres d'histoire de la mode on parlera
de 15 jours mais qu'est ce que tu penses
que tu as apporté des belles 2
je fais aussi découler des impôts
[Musique]
un beau boudia pond way et puis aussi
j'adore le baiia des folklores oui
histoire géographie
oui et puis les portes est il sait pas
le mélange des rayures avec les écossais
avec les petites fleurs
oui oui je sais mais non c'est quoi tu
détestes plus en france bungie qui tu es
diallo d'abord avant de dire ce que tu
adores ce que tu aimes le moins ça me
samsung de temps en temps c'est des gens
ce qu'est mon image tellement dédiant
cela est hilare
ils critiquent ira ça ira mais
finalement c'est que ses complices en
valeur est ce que tu préfères de tous en
france non c'est ne connais pas toutes
en france surtout paris médiator j'adore
les aime bien le baril
dans la nuit
dans le café d'un an
soit je meurs comme fans et tous à tous
les hommes bien qu'ils adorent et puis à
paris c'était mon beau une ville la plus
belle ville du monde tu crois avec lui
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus